the taliban are known for their
ultra-strict interpretation of islam and
harsh legal punishments but at the same
time they're one of the biggest players
in afghanistan's illegal drug trade the
united nations office on drugs and crime
estimates over 80 percent of global
opium and heroin supplies are produced
in the country the gross value of afghan
opiate exports is estimated at between
1.5 and 3 billion dollars per year joe
piersante saw many parts of this trade
up close as a special agent with the
dea's fast teams he was involved in
counter narcotics operations and raids
against the taliban's heroin production
network
it's crazy i can describe
it to people and i've done many times
but until you're really over there
you just can't really get a
grasp of it you just can't believe
people are still living like this it's
like the stone ages over there a lot of
places there's no running water they're
living with their animals
um the labs are very crude just with
like 55 gallon drums and
other things like that but they just
make such good quality
heroin
just hitting these locations
or rating them
they're well behind enemy lines and this
is their source of income
so most of them not they're going to
fight like hell to protect this
during a mission with afghan
counterparts and australian special
forces in 2011 pirsanti was severely
wounded by enemy gunfire as they were
trying to leave the area i was providing
covering fire
for my teammates
to get on the helicopter
once everybody got on or near the
helicopter me and my teammates my team
later tapped me and said let's go
i turned left to run on the helicopter
and that's when i was struck
in the head piersante was left blind
from his injuries and later retired from
the dea
he's now a motivational speaker and
professional bodybuilder he says most of
the heroine is smuggled through iran and
pakistan and ends up in europe only five
to ten percent of it reaches the united
states pirsanti says the taliban have
also expanded into producing hashish and
crystal methamphetamine depending on the
year's harvest opium accounts for
between 6 and 11 of afghanistan's gdp in
2020 about 224 000 hectares of opium
poppies were cultivated that's the
surface area of about 32 000 soccer
fields vanda felba brown a senior fellow
at brookings who has written extensively
about afghanistan's drug trade says when
the taliban first came to power in the
1990s they actually tried to ban opium
as it started expanding in the country
in 94 uh it encountered extensive
popular cultivation in the core
provinces where the taliban operated and
very originated kandahar and talmud and
its first impulse for religious reason
was to ban poke cultivation but it very
quickly generated revolts
uh even the areas with strongest tribal
and other support for the taliban were
all of a sudden opposing to taliban
and so the taliban quickly realized that
trying to suppress copy was
unsustainable end of 95 it allowed
cultivation to proceed and soon it
realized well cultivation is taking
place why don't we tax it so by 96 it's
taxing opium puppy phil brown says the
taliban got around the religious
contradiction of opium by prohibiting
and punishing its use within the country
and that selling it to infidels abroad
was another form of jihad but she says
they aren't the only ones in afghanistan
involved in the trade warlords militias
gangs and even government officials have
ties to the poppy and many farmers and
their families depend on it to survive
in 2017 it was estimated poppy
cultivation provided up to 590 000
full-time jobs philba brown says opium
is so entrenched in the economy that
even if it were possible to completely
get rid of it the spillover effects on
the local population would be disastrous
if opium bobby disappeared
through magic wand it would be
catastrophic economically for the afghan
people and it would be catastrophic for
any government that was in power so
in this case right now the taliban it
would generate great privation
malnutrition
and huge political instability
now ironically we might not be in a
situation where puppy disappears but we
might be in a situation where much of
the international market disappears
because a lot of
the north american markets have seen a
heroine not from afghanistan from latin
america displaced by synthetic opioids
from china and india
and so imagine the situation where the
taliban for international legitimacy
reasons or desire to get economic aid
out of russia bans copy for a year or
two and then it decides to lift the ban
well it may find that its west european
markets are no longer interested in
afghan opium because the opioids now
used are synthetic opioids from china
and india since retaking power in
afghanistan the taliban have publicly
stated that they would ban drug
production but similar to their pledges
to respect human rights and press
freedoms there is a general distrust in
the taliban to follow through pirsanti
believes if anything drug production
will simply increase under new taliban
leadership from all estimates the last
year the production of poppy was way up
and um
everybody believes and all the
experts believe it's just going to get
worse it's going to explode even more
especially since you know we're pulling
out and all our coalition partners are
pulling out they're going to go
unchecked
[Music]
and just continue to get you know
millions and billions of dollars to
fund their terror networks to me it's
pretty scary
[Music]